how good is machine translation going to
get
before it plateaus off and it can't get
any better
maybe i should let you answer first um i
think there isn't a single answer to
that because there uh
as we've we've seen actually here and in
previous events um
there isn't a single mt quality there
isn't a single monolithic curve on which
we're growing that mt systems just get
better and better from year to year
depends on so many different factors and
parameters so some mt is going to get
very very good it's already very good
and it's going to get really very good
almost i would say human quality it's
not going to be human quality uh
perfectly i think in in almost
all cases but some mt is just much much
more challenging and and when i say some
it breaks along many different
dimensions one of the obvious one is
language pair there are certain language
pairs where we're doing way better than
other language pairs and it's going to
stay like that for a while there are
certain
genres types of data and where we do
much better than others it's going to be
like that for a while there are certain
modalities you know uh speech for
example is more challenging uh chat is
more challenging uh
basically i i think that in certain
ways in which we can carve this space
by um by language pair by consistency of
domain by authoring by type of data
there are going to be basically some
combinations where we get very very good
and there are going to be others uh that
we're not getting good and it's actually
important to have the expertise to
distinguish between these in order to
know how to actually
basically focus our efforts and focus
our investment yeah i'll give you a more
personal answer um knowing you for the
last few years
so it wasn't that long ago fred that you
were died in the world rule-based mt uh
proponent
and uh via statistical post editing
we've managed to persuade you over the
last two or three years that there might
be some future for you and your
institution in using statistical machine
translation now that i consider a major
paradigm shift getting you to change
your uh
your view
on on you know what might be possible in
such a short period of time um who knows
what's around the corner i mean but
clearly people are you know a bit like
intel you know um you know the pc you
have on your desk you know they're
they're two
cpus you know two orders of cpu ahead of
what we what we can buy now in the shops
so and people are playing around with
different types of empty system and
you've seen lots of different hybrid
uh offerings spoken about uh over the
last couple of days um and clearly you
know it's up to us to kind of road test
those and bug fix them and uh and but
pretty soon you know they'll be
available or they are available already
for anyone to play around with
and um you know it's uh
i mean we will start to as we've heard
today we start to then you know move
sort of beyond the syntactic level to
the semantic level and then beyond
um but you know mt is hard let's not
forget that mt is not easy none of us
are going to be out of a job any day
soon i don't think you know we're not
going to solve this tomorrow um but uh
you know things are i think the future
is bright for a long time and i was
saying how long the other night
um you know this statistical you know
this data-driven uh model isn't going to
go away you know i think that's pretty
much entrenched now so whatever is
around the corner will have to be driven
by the data so i'm just wondering if you
think uh certain types of technology
may drive it all faster for for example
mobile
we're talking about the iphone
and that is becoming ubiquitous versus
say
heaven forbid
but i'm just wondering if we focus in on
certain types of applications
versus being very dispersed on a lot of
our mt development if we wouldn't make
more progress
i think
that's a fantastic question thank you
for asking that
it's a very smart question and the
reason is
i think
we have we would have not sat today
around the table
and there would be no statistical
machine translation field unless
al gore had even invented the internet
so
he didn't invent the internet but unless
the internet was invented and i'm
serious now so
natural language processing as a field
was in the backwoods
nobody cared about natural language
until the web came along nobody gave a
damn about people with our skills
and then the web came along and then
suddenly we became relevant we were
doing exactly the same kind of stuff
that we did before but now suddenly we
became relevant
and we had lots of data and we had lots
of stuff to work with that it was
completely unimaginable to get
15 years ago or 20 years ago people at
ibm when they started its fiscal machine
translation they went to the canadian
parliament and they left with a truck
full of tapes the the parliament
proceedings and that's how they kicked
off statistical machine translation
we didn't have to do that in the 1990s
towards the end of the 1990s so i think
what they i think the the question is
extremely good because technology
enabled us to get here or a particular
platform now what's the next platform
that would drive the next
generation of technolo of progress in
this field i think that's a very smart
question i never thought about it but i
think it's worth thinking about it
i think there's a value in diversity and
in cross-pollination so you you do not
focus on just one thing and and pursue
that
and
you can you can have an emphasis is in
fact good if you change that emphasis
occasionally because you learned
something from what you did before and
you apply it to the next thing
so um the mt people stole a lot of of
research from the speech people right
and there's
a lot of common technologies and it is
good and there are people who move back
and forth between these areas and and
enrich them each by by carrying over
their their experiences one final word
from my end on this i agree with daniel
and
what the chris said i think the
connection isn't going to be
immediate it's not going to be something
like oh mobile so we can build mt
systems that go along with mobile i
think the change into mobile as
basically as a technology is going to
generate new types of data that we can't
imagine quite yet that are going to turn
out to be useful for mt in ways that
we're not thinking about yet so for
example like until twitter came along
people didn't know really what you know
twitter came along and then suddenly
there's just these vast amounts of data
that twitter generating and now we're
finding what kind of
cool kind of information we can find out
about social networks and about people
and about what they're talking about
that we couldn't imagine before before
twitter was there and maybe that
information is useful for machine
translation i don't know yet but things
like that are going to happen it's not i
don't think it's going to be build mt
for mobile it's going to be mobile
generates data that we find out is
extremely useful
yeah i was going to say you know i think
that
the
the future probably is is is this is a
related question or related uh an answer
to a related question that you didn't
ask
but um i think you know you'll rather
than see these large monolithic pieces
of software you know what mobile and
handheld devices has facilitated is you
know what smaller apps um and again you
know there are lots of people in this
room or outside of this room who can who
can think of very clever ways in which
they can build on uh the mt systems that
we can make available but i think the
you know the the the future is is a
personalized service you know building
personalized engines for you you know
already the the sort of uh you and i
could ask the same query inside google
and we get different answers you know
geared towards our respective uh
histories inside these search engines so
uh you know more personalized mt you
know geared specifically to your
requirements versus somebody else's i
think that's a you know that's that's
here now
and uh just add to that i think along
those lines things like text analytics
are going to become even more important
so analyzing what a user is usually
talking about and letting that inform
the type of mt you're going to perform
in terms of personalizing even more to
the individual user rather than to
perhaps the client or the company so
you're talking on kind of small scale
translation needs there
as the mt
engines get more and more uh
better at what they do what would uh
what is your prediction on the
on the role or even possibly the
ultimate fate of post editing with with
regards to
uh
you know will it will will mtu end up
completely replacing it is post editing
really just a stop gap until it gets
good enough what are what are your
thoughts
of course post editing is an excellent
data source for uh new new uh
mt engines and new domains uh better
coverage of languages that aren't
covered well before
so there's um
i said microsoft wants to localize its
products into 100 languages we don't
have empty engines for 100 languages
yet
i don't know of anybody who has a hand
coverage uh between between 100
languages and i do know that
that
they're not good right they require
a lot of post editing
so
as i mentioned i i encourage uh
encourage people to a human translate
meaning
ship in human human translation quality
uh less in the major languages and more
in the in the low data languages in
order to help
bridge that uh overcome that gap
so my sense is that post editing is
going to be with us for a long long time
but it's not going to be again uniform
it's not going to be that the same
amount of post editing is necessary for
different applications of mt and
different uh domains different languages
but also i think we're going to see
in the short term
um a real focus on
ramp up improvements as
by leveraging post editing so as as we
feedback post post-edited
output back into our systems using
various adaptation techniques we'll see
that that leads mt systems to improve
quickly so that we can reduce the amount
of post editing that's necessary
as a function of time
but uh then there's going to be then
other domains other other applications
in which post editing is going to be
with us
on a more larger scale
you